[Music]
it's the thick mudder we're at lake
elsinore about to kick this [ __ ] off
we're 400 strong when you get muddy when
you get thicker
we're going to get tired we need time
fine you know what i'm saying we're
gonna have fun we can help each other
out i appreciate you guys coming out the
first wave has already gone so i came a
little late i'm on one leg but we're
gonna [ __ ] get it done i appreciate
you guys stay thick let's do this thing
finishes strong all right
why they call you the fire boy cause
everything that i do fire boy i was the
one with the can of the gas and the
matches the propane the tank and the
lighter boy
i was the one with the vision yeah now
they all look at me different now i'm
the one out here making decisions
looking around i don't see competition i
just started going in but i don't wanna
hurt the feelings all these thoughts up
in my head
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no manager just got a gift like that boy
in the main edge oops i'm in manger the
game is in danger my peers are in danger
man read him a prayer i just found my
angle and got to the green a man i just
teed off with no l like decatur i'm
right out the gate and i'm keeping it
players but whenever i get done they all
seem scared for the billys i will lash
out like the girl with the green hair
flow so premiere
this one with this going by faster
my hands are [ __ ] freezing from all
the the cold water obstacles like
goddamn i'm like
so
this is going by faster but the
discomfort is my trainer
man who is this boy in here going off
man let's pull his car we don't know his
name they said you gotta go all in i
told them like a poker game they think
i'm trying to be lil dicky i told him i
promise i'm not dead i'm just a nobody
that got a chance then wrote his first
album in five days thick mudder crew
though we had some monsters man some of
these girls are dominating
the thick girls are dominating
mark doesn't do well in the cold
jane chappelle are about two hours
behind
it's a disaster
home stretch
i'm fun
yo i was like yeah i need to assemble a
crew i found the strongest
dudes of the pack and i gathered them i
said we go at our own pace
right we've been running myself running
we all don't think we've been doing
anything but look at us
i'm here baby
[Music]
[Music]
man who is this boy in here going off
man let's pull his car we don't know his
name they said you gotta go all in i
told him that like a poker game they
think i'm trying to be lil dicky i told
him i promise i'm not dead i'm just a
nobody they got a chance then wrote his
first album in five days they gassed me
up this ain't movies then screenshot my
[ __ ] to their friends and they throw
[ __ ] but when they see me in person they
don't really say [ __ ] it turns to a
quiet place i feel like i haven't
started yet but i had to give them a
little taste the king in the stink [ __ ]
was cool but they ain't hurt my real
[ __ ] fire boy on the way
[Music]
that's it another tough mudder the thick
mudder is in the books it's our second
one good to see you second one uh we got
a bunch more coming up the gold's hit
six this year so
if you missed out on this thick mudder
we'll be doing it nationwide come join
the thick mudder man we had so much fun
over 400 people signed up
400 in different heats all thickies
getting it done uh chappelle and j fish
about nine hours so that's cool and the
rest is about two but oh it's five hours
yeah that's a long time
don't do five hours you know don't walk
it my hammies are shot my leg is swollen
i think with a few weeks rest i'll be
good man but that's it this is tough
mudder life man thick mud in life i love
it see you at the next one
[Music]